best friends trip this is gonna be
iconic
you do understand this is a work trip
for me Audrey I got you look at me
you're thinking about a dick damn it
you're right
I love a grand Adventure I heard that if
you keep up with Chinese businessmen
they respect you more
listen up listen up listen up
you're gonna plug are you gonna play is
it a condom you look like you've had a
lot of things in your [__] I'm not a
lot of things just one thing but maybe
different varieties of that one thing
look at me look at me look at me go
stick your hand up there like a claw
machine trying to get the stuff there
if you do not know where you come from
how do you know who you are I'm just a
garbage American who only speaks English
and a little Golem
n they are fancy offices do you guys
have that here yeah we have it's the all
over the world
are you horny
sex isn't shameful it's beautiful like
the noises
look at me
show them there's some boards in this
house there's some [__] in this house
I'm not racist you don't like Boba and
you never [__] an Asian guys damn
still when I masturbate I sometimes
fantasize about Splinter he's Asian he's
a rat he's a good father